one day more until the 2018 midterms
both parties make their closing
arguments we take a look at the latest
outbreak of anti-semitism in New York
City and Gloria Steinem and Barbara
Streisand
are back and better than ever I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh so many things to talk about because
we have one day more until the midterm
elections and tomorrow we are doing some
pretty awesome stuff you're gonna want
to tune in not only do I have my normal
episode we also are doing our election
night special which we do for your
pleasure not mine so be there I mean if
I'm gonna put that sort of sacrifice and
you may as well be there because come on
people come on if I'm gonna sacrifice my
night you need to suffer with me but
first let's talk a little bit about what
you do for your legal services so as a
business owner as a person involved in
business we need legal services on a
constant basis and let me tell you
something lawyers are extraordinarily
expensive but LegalZoom is not and that
is why you need Legal Zoom they are
there to give you the tools you need so
you can focus on running your business I
know about Legal Zoom way back when when
I was just doing like incorporation
documents when I was doing wills and
trusts but you can use Legal Zoom for a
wide variety of legal services more than
a million Americans have used Legal Zoom
to start their businesses but even after
your business is set up Legal Zoom can
still help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contractor
views those are all part of running your
business and you don't know what you're
doing which is why you need a lawyer
they even have crap today bibs a
business legal plan so you can get
advice for your business from vetted
independent attorneys and tax
professionals licensed in every state
the best part is you won't get charged
by the hour since Legal Zoom is not in
fact a law firm visit legalzoom.com
right now to take care of your business
before the year winds down and for
special savings be sure to enter promo
code been in the referral box at
checkout
that is promo code been for special
savings only at legalzoom.com again that
is legalzoom.com go check it out right
now legalzoom.com and use it that promo
code been in the referral box to check
out so let them know we sent you an for
special savings so check that out right
now
alright so tomorrow tomorrow it begins
is the great election of our time now I
have to say there are a lot of folks who
constantly say that whatever election is
happening right now is the most
important election of our lifetime and
this is not the most important election
of our lifetime it's an important
election just like most elections are
important it's important in the sense
that the direction of the country could
shift pretty remarkably if the Democrats
were to win for example the house and
the Senate setting up their run against
president from in 2020 it could also
shift against intersectional politics
from the left if Republicans were to
hold the house if Republicans were to
hold the house in spite of the hatred of
President Trump that would be a pretty
remark
we'll turn about and again the only time
since 2002 there that the party in power
has held the the the seats that they
have gained in a in a house election by
2006 the elections shifted the control
of the house 2010 the election shifted
to control the house 2014 the control of
the Senate shifted so this would be the
first time in an off-year election in 16
years that the party in power actually
held the houses that it held before the
election that's a possibility okay so I
don't want to discount that possibility
I will not say it's a likelihood but it
is a possibility so for example here's a
Wall Street Journal poll there's a chart
of polls from the Wall Street Journal
and how in the past those have matched
up with the actual performance right so
the Wall Street Journal poll several
years ago it showed that the Republicans
were leading and then it showed that the
Republicans won like 60 votes in the
house when all was said and done right
now the Republicans are are down in the
polls about 20 seats so if that's where
it ends up right if the final Wall
Street Journal poll shows a seven-point
Democratic lead that is consistent with
a 16 seat GOP loss so well there are a
lot of folks saying that this could be
up to a 40 seat win for Democrats it
could just be a 16c win for Democrats
which means that Republicans hold the
house that is within the range of
possibilities for folks who are saying
that it is impossible for Republicans to
hold the house that obviously is untrue
it is unlikely that they hold the house
the late-breaking polls are breaking
against Republicans if the election had
been held three weeks ago in the midst
of saga Kavanagh I think the Republicans
probably hold the house or at least
there's a good shot that they do
tomorrow night I think that the chances
are not great the Republicans hold the
house the new CNN poll shows Democrats
leading Republicans by 13 points in the
final generic ballot 55 to 42 democrats
leading among independents by 14 among
women by 27 and in some of the
bellwether states things like Florida
where Ron de santis Congress person who
I think is really great running against
Andrew Gilliam who's a radical left
Democrat for the governorship of Florida
the early voting is actually cutting in
favor of Democrats which obviously cuts
against Republicans not just for Oly
early voting but more broadly as well
the problem with trying to forecast all
these elections is that taking that
generic ballot poll that shows Democrats
up heavily and not looking at each
individual district is
not being honest about how this is done
the truth is that congressional
elections run a lot more like the
Electoral College than the popular vote
so let's be real
in 2016 the National vote totals were
very close to the national polling but
the Electoral College did not skew that
way the same thing is true in these
election these in these congressional
districts so just because you have a
congressional district in which
everything is even and the National vote
totals are wildly out of whack the
National vote totals don't matter all
that matters is what's happening inside
that district so if I had to forecast
this thing right now you know if I were
to go out on a limb I say Democrats win
40 seats if I don't go out on a limb I
say Democrats win 30 seats and win
slight control of the House and
Republicans maintain the Senate maybe
even pick up a seat or two now let's
talk about the final pitches that are
being made in the run-up to the in the
run-up to this election because one of
the things that's driving me absolutely
up a wall and I think it is for a lot of
folks I'm a conservative side of the
aisle is the complete and absolute
dishonesty of about what both parties
are contending so I've freely admitted
on this show that I think that president
Trump's pitch in the final days of this
election about the migrant caravan being
this grave threat to the Republic I
think that is exaggerated I do not think
12,000 people are descending on mass on
the border in militarily violent ways in
order to invade the country I don't
think that's what this is going to be I
think by the time this reaches the
border it'll be several hundred people
who go to a port of entry apply for
asylum
some are accepted some are rejected I
don't think you actually need 15,000
troops who by the way are not allowed to
actually shoot people because that would
be a violation of Posse Comitatus right
you can't use domestic army to enforce
foreign policy or state or state law you
can't actually do that so they're
actually going down there right now and
they're putting up like concertina wire
they're putting up barbed wires that
people can't cross the border all of
which is fine if President Trump thinks
it's necessary but you know the
president Trump's closing pitch that
this is a massive crisis I think is
exaggerated I think he should be pushing
the economy although I understand why
he's doing what he's doing the reason
he's doing what he's doing is because
the Democratic pitch has basically come
down to Republicans are all racist
bigots it's amazing in 2016 after they
lost a national election on the basis of
that pitch they are now reverting to
that pitch the pitch is that if
publicans don't vote Democrat they're a
bunch of racist sexist big @ homophobe
anti-semites this is the pitch that
Democrats are making as they're closing
pitch and that is not a good pitch it
isn't no matter how much you don't like
how Republicans are running Democrats
are running an intersectional identity
politics campaign there's been a lot of
talk from the left about Republicans
running this identity politics campaign
and even if that's true that does not
change the fact that Democrats are also
running an identity politics campaign
and here's my great fear coming out of
this election like just trying to put on
my objective observer cap for one second
and listen I'm a partisan I want
Republicans to win tomorrow I think that
if Democrats take control of the house
then it's going to forward the worst
impulses among them and it's going to
lead to terrible terrible policy because
it turns out it's not just a rejection
of Trump to put Democrats in charge of
policy it also means an embrace of
radical left policy and there are costs
to trying to punish Trump at the ballot
box and that cost is putting people like
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez in position to
Alec to actually shape policy putting
people like Andrew Gilliam in position
to shape policy so here is here's the
big problem putting on my objective
observer cap if you are if you are
somebody who doesn't like the tone and
tenor of our politics if the Republicans
retain the House Democrats will become
ever more wild and many Republicans are
going to think that president Trump's
more ridiculous excesses are good right
that it's an affirmative it's an
affirmative recommendation of president
Trump's more ridiculous excesses just as
in 2016 Trump won and so the party
decided what we need is to act more like
Trump you could get that as a reaction
from the right to the Republicans
winning tomorrow night on the Left if
Democrats win it's going to be a
full-scale belief on the left and a
heartfelt belief that the only way to
win elections is to be as vile and nasty
and intersectional and slanderous of the
other side as humanly possible so I
don't see our politics getting better
they stun anything that happens tomorrow
evening now if I had to measure where do
I think our politics get worse I think
if the Left wins tomorrow night then our
politics get significantly worse in a
variety of ways not only because the
Democrats are then emboldened to embrace
the worst among them but also because
the Democratic policy comes along with a
lot of negatives their policy is
extraordinarily radical and I know we've
ignored that policy all the way through
this election because every
thing revolves around the black hole of
trumpism but the fact is that the
Democrats electing Democrats is not a
cost-free proposition and the reason I'm
saying this to you know moderates and
leftists in the audience liberals in the
audience not leftist liberals in the
audience the reason I'm saying this is
because if you want to make every
election a referendum on Trump then what
you have to recognize is that there are
costs to that referendum those costs
come in terms of policy and you can see
that the left is already embracing this
intersectional politics they've not
moved away from it they're not unifying
the country the great lie that the
Democrats are putting forward and their
acolytes are putting forward is that
President Trump is dividing the country
but Democrats will unite the country
that is a lie I think President Trump
has been quite divisive on cultural
issues I think Democrats have been just
as divisive or more divisive than
Republicans that isn't what about ISM
that's a condemnation of everybody who's
attempting to divide us on the basis of
politics but I'll tell you what's even
more divisive is people gaslighting
people on the Left suggesting that if
you're on the right you're okay with all
of the excesses of President Trump but
if you're on the left you're a wonderful
good kind decent clean beautiful human
being just by nature and this is what
you are seeing even from you know the
quote-unquote moderate Republicans who
say we have to vote for Democrats in
order to in order to stop Trump ISM so
you're gonna affirmatively vote for the
party of Keith Ellison in order to stop
Donald Trump explain to me how that one
works I understand the argument as I did
in 2016 that you don't like anybody
you're staying home I get that but to
suggest that a that a in an attempt to
dream like the Democratic Party is
somehow going to make the country better
is just bizarre and the media are
pushing as hard as they possibly can on
this I mean the media have just been
when folks say honestly when folks say
that the media is unbiased I don't know
how you could possibly say that and look
at the reality of what the media do on a
daily basis today CNN tweeted this out
see that remember the ad that President
Trump put out there about the caravan
and it just opposed the caravan to an
illegal immigrant killer and I said that
this ad was inflammatory and
over-the-top but it was effective and it
was not racist here's CNN's take quote
CNN has made it abundantly clear in at
editorial coverage that this ad is
racist when presented with an
opportunity to be paid to take a version
of this ad we declined those are the
facts
so much journalism remember CNN is
supposed to be an objective outlet it is
not their job to simply declare ads
racist that actually are not racist
but this is what they do and this is
what they do on a regular basis it's
pretty astonishing CNN fails to report
facts on a regular basis as well or this
is the same CNN that suggested the
President Trump was responsible for the
shooting in Pittsburgh that he was
responsible for the bombing attempts
against Democrats well there was a there
is a guy who's arrested over the weekend
for vandalizing a synagogue in New York
City CNN failed to report that this guy
was a democratic activist who
volunteered on Obama's presidential
campaign and was a former City Hall
intern who worked on combating hate
crimes
that's CNN factual factual CNN and it
gets worse it gets worse I'll explain in
just a second but first let's talk about
how you do your postage so I know you
think that the only way to do postage is
you send one of your folks down to the
post office to wait in line and then
they have to spend time there and
they've spend money there well the fact
is you can get all the great services of
the post office at stamps comm with
stamps calm you can access all those
amazing services right from your desk
24/7 when it's convenient for you buy in
print official US postage for any letter
any package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier
picks it up just click print mail you're
done it could not be easier we use
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices on a regular basis it saves us
time which means it saves us money right
now use promo code Shapiro for our
special offer up to 55 bucks of free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go to stamps calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in promo code Shapiro again
that stamps calm enter promo code
Shapiro stamps calm use that promo code
so you get that free offer again 55
bucks free postage a digital scale and a
four week trial when you go to stamps
calm and click on that radio microphone
at the top of the page and type in
Shapiro go check it out right now that
stamps calm promo code Shapiro so the
media obviously have a stake in this
election cycle in making it a referendum
on Trump and ignoring the fact that
there is another party that's part of
this election now in 2016 the great lie
was that that was a referendum on Trump
it was not a referendum on Trump
there's a referendum on Hillary Clinton
and because it was a referendum on
Hillary Clinton Trump won in an off-year
election it's usually a referendum on
the president that's usually the way
that it works
but again this is a two-party system and
that means it should be a referendum on
Democrats - but here are the headlines
from the Washington Post these were the
two leading headlines at the Washington
Post website as of last night quote
midterms test whether Republicans not
named Trump can win by stoking racial
animosity so much journalism in so much
term because Trump is stoking racial
animosity and so are Republicans
everywhere everywhere what are their
examples in this piece of Republicans
stoking racial animosity a bunch of non
Republican groups running ads non
associated with Republican campaigns and
Steve King who is condemned by the
National Republican Congressional
Committee head last week that's an
example of the Republicans still
congressional fears that was headline
number one headline number two quote
full trumpism the president's
apocalyptic attacks reach a new level of
falsity that's objective journalism in
from the Washington Post then you wonder
why Trump rails against the fake news
guys that's why he's railing against the
fake news sometimes he's being over
broad sometimes he's attacking people
because they are covering the news when
he attacks the Washington Post for this
sort of coverage that is not wrong I
don't remember any similar headline
about Barack Obama in the aftermath of
if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor I don't have the executive
power to green-light illegal immigration
and the Iran deal is going to be
fantastic because the Iranian regime is
moderating I don't remember any of this
sort of media coverage from the
Washington Post the president's
apocalyptic attacks reach a new level of
apocalyptic what is Trump bringing about
the apocalypse you have three point
seven percent unemployment and record
economic growth where's the apocalypse
exactly but this sort of media coverage
has become the usual on the left because
if they want to make it a referendum
about Trump that's the only way they
think they can win and you will see that
the intersectional politics of the left
has has reached epic proportions again
more media bias ABC News trotted out
this chart hey here's a chart that ABC
News trotted out
it said candidates going into the
general election including House Senate
and governor's races female 278
candidates 214 Democrats 64 Republicans
non-white 202 148 Democrats 54
Republicans openly LGBTQ 25 all
Democrats okay so here's the question
who gives a crap who cares who cares how
many candidates are female or non-white
or openly gay or transgender like who
cares about that
ABC News cares because they are deeply
involved in ensconced in intersectional
politics when folks claim that Trump is
using identity politics remember the
identity politics did not start on the
right it started on the left but if
you're gonna run a campaign and you've
got nothing else to run on you have to
run against Trump's quote-unquote
identity politicking so Anna Navarro who
is the left favorite Republican which is
to say she's no longer a Republican she
was on CNN with Chris Cuomo aka
block of human actually like a block of
wood and here is the Anna Navarro
explaining that Trump is a racist pig
and this of course makes Democrats very
happy to hear CNN has law honestly
they've lost the threat over at CNN
whatever they think they are they're
obviously just a wing of the Democratic
Party - I think they're more radical
than MSNBC at this point which is an
amazing thing to say but this is what it
is - Anna Navarro making the case that
Trump is a racist pig therefore vote for
Democrats people who think he's racist
he has said so many racist you call him
a racist racist of criminals and rapists
El Salvador in Haiti are poles he is a
racist pig okay so he's a race' they're
gonna shout that on TV until they win
okay they're not gonna put any of those
things in context or simply say okay
fine so Trump says things that I think
are racist does that mean that I have to
vote against the entire Republican Party
or all of those people are all of those
people the same as President Trump of
course not
but here's the thing so Anna Navarro
writes a piece over at CNN and it's
telling rich says my Florida absentee
ballot had been sitting on my kitchen
counter unopened for more than two weeks
every day I avoided it as if it was a
Zika infected mosquito I finally filled
it out and then i schlepped it in my bag
for a few more days before putting it in
the mail I was giving myself a chance to
change my mind I wanted to delay the
unavoidable I am a lifelong Republican
since I began voting I've always voted
for Republicans running in state races
in Florida this year I filled out my
ballot for Democrat Andrew Gilliam and
on Thursday I put it in the mail
Rhonda Santos a Republican ran a primary
campaign in which he portrayed himself
as Donald Trump's mini-me
his signature issue during
primarily was building a wall which is
weird because Florida's not a border
state
it's a peninsula surrounded by water on
three sides I don't want a trump echo
chamber for governor in Florida I want a
governor who puts the interest of the
state above loyalty to a president of
his party but I also didn't want to vote
for Gilliam I'm a centrist he's a
progressive that word kind of scares me
he wants to raise corporate taxes I'm
against that I think it would impede
Florida's economic growth there's an
unresolved issue of an FBI investigation
involving the city of Tallahassee while
he was mayor well the unresolved issue
is that he was likely involved in
corruption and targeted by the FBI for
that corruption in public private
projects he says there are loyalty
issues for me Jeb Bush is supporting two
Santa's but then he says the 2016 oh
this is Anna Navarro the 2016 election
taught us all an important lesson some
things in life are binary choices
there's too much at stake in these
elections often in Florida elections are
decided by one percentage point or less
writing and Mickey Mouse is not an
option and she says that simply because
DeSantis is supportive of Trump that
means that she can't vote for two
Santa's and and then she cites Cesar
siop who is that crazy person with the
Trump ban who is sending pipe bombs to
people it's it's just it's astonishing
so her solution is I'm now going to vote
for I'm now going to vote for Andrew
Gilliam his response to Charlottesville
is she's like my Trump the Muslim ban
the national anthem controversy the list
is endless it disgusts me then not even
a week after a madman who may have been
triggered by the hysteria surrounding
migrants killed 11 Jews in a house of
worship in Pittsburgh Trump is back to
his old playbook of demonizing
immigrants Gilliam is out there a happy
warrior campaigning on a positive
message so in other words you think that
Trump is all of these bad things they're
gonna vote for Andrew Gilliam a radical
leftist who is a close associate of
dream defenders an intersectional racist
group that is wildly anti-israel who's
deeply involved in corruption in the
city of Tallahassee and are going to do
all of this because Ron de santis is
nice to Trump so your solution is to
vote for a radical Democrat because you
don't like Trump who believe it or not
is not on the ballot tomorrow that's
your solution this is why I have to say
I think that all of this is just a lie I
think the folks who are voting Democrat
tomorrow a lot of the folks who are
voting Democrat who proclaim themselves
moderates are forcibly blinding
themselves to what the Democratic Party
is in order to reach that conclusion the
the racist charge
the Republicans is the strongest club in
the Democrat bag but they used it
against Mitt Romney they used against
george w bush and they'll use it against
donald trump - now i think they're using
against trump you know a little bit more
justifiably in the sense that Trump says
ridiculous things but to use it against
the entire Republican Party is
completely unjustified and say I'm going
to vote for a radical intersectional
racist Democrat because that is some
sort of rebuke to Trump how that makes
the country better is beyond me
now in a second I want to talk a little
bit more about this we'll talk about
what the actual Democrats are actually
what they could be running on if we
actually took a look at what Democrats
are seriously talking about in just a
second first let's talk about you
dressing better okay so endo Chino is
the way that you dress better they have
a huge variety of fabrics colors and
patterns and makes Indo chinos super
stylish there's not an excuse from
wearing an ill-fitting suit hey you went
to the yeah I know you went to your
local chain store and you picked up a
suit on sale and now it drapes off you
like Julie Andrews made it for you in
Sound of Music but not quite as tailored
you don't need that suit but you needed
something from Indo Chino
especially because tailored suits are
now available at great prices you're
talking high quality low price it's a
unique experience actually in a know
Chino you are playing designer in
consultation with their style guides I
went over to their Santa Monica offices
I had a tailor fit outfit me actually
went there in person checked out all the
fabrics checked out all of the designs
they have monograms they have lapels
that like you actually get to choose it
as though as though it's Savile Row its
Savile Row it's really fantastic go
check it out Indo Chino is North
America's leading made-to-measure
menswear company this is a stylist at
one of their showrooms have them take
your measurements personally or you can
measure yourself at home and shop online
at Indo chino dot-com and watch as the
compliments roll in November is Black
Friday season meaning the 2018 s lowest
prices up to 70% off everything the
theme is all about stepping out from
backstage okay right you're stepping out
from backstage right now because guess
what you've been behind and now you got
all the holiday parties gotta look good
I got a hot date with your wife or with
your significant other go check it out
right now enzo Chino calm and right now
my listeners can receive Black Friday
pricing by using promo code shapiro a
checkout that seventy percent off the
regular price for a made-to-measure suit
shipping is free Indo Chino compromised
Shapiro for up to 70 percent off you're
not gonna look better than an endo Chino
suit go check it out right now so the
Democrats final pitch of
of course of course is Trump's a racist
now what that has to do with marsha
blackburn or what that has to do with
martha mcsalley
a combat vet or what that has to do with
the wide variety of republicans running
across the country is beyond me
but i guess that if you're gonna make it
a referendum on trump being mean and
republicans being racist we'll see how
that goes for you Tom Perez the head of
the DNC tried to track this out to again
the entire name of the game for
Democrats is misdirect away from your
own party direct it toward president
Trump this is why it would have been
better if President Trump simply receded
into the background over the past few
months and had everybody talk about the
economy and talk about Republican
successes and points out the Democrats
have lost their minds which they have
the Cavanagh thing would have gone just
as you would have expected it to go and
that would have been the only headline
left now obviously the last two weeks
leading up to the election have been
about pipe bombs and shootings in
Pittsburgh and that's allowed the
Democrats really ratchet up the rhetoric
on Trump's supposed divisive nasir as
Tom Perez making that closing pitch and
now what you see in the closing argument
is dog-whistle politics appeals to
racist just the the worst of America
yeah this stuff I sort of hate this this
dog-whistle politics routine your dog
was because what's the implication then
I'm the dog that you're the dog then
what Trump actually has to do to win an
election is dog whistle to you you
weren't gonna vote for Republicans
before but now he has said something
racially tinged and you went oh I hate
those brown people and now you're gonna
go vote for President Trump and his
party even though he's not on the ballot
the reason Democrats are so focused I'm
talking about Trump is because they've
got nothing the same party the same
party that is ripping Trump as an
anti-semite and ripping Republicans as
racist that same party is defending
Keith Ellison who is Tom Perez is number
two over at the DNC Tom Perez went on
national television and called his
ex-girlfriend a liar I thought they were
supposed to believe all women but
apparently not when it comes to keith
ellison now I think Keith's Allison's
ex-girlfriend is lying then is that what
you're saying I think Keith Ellison's
ex-girlfriend deserves to be heard and
deserves to be treated with dignity and
deserves to have a fair and full
investigation and that's exactly what
has been done okay in other words yes I
think that she is lying
what do you Democrats actually have to
run on the answer is nothing they've got
nothing to actually run them the record
stinks the policies that
to push stink the economy is
historically good America is in a better
position on foreign policy than it was
certainly three years ago in reality the
Democratic platform is far too radical
for the American people and what in the
in the secrecy of their own little
rallies Democrats will tell you exactly
what they want to do and it has nothing
to do with Donald Trump what they
actually want to do is take over the
house take over the Senate come out of
the presidency and you think at that
point they're gonna say listen we've
really we've fought back against racism
and sexism and bigotry and homophobia
now everything is cool let's moderate
let's tack to the center
let's find unity do you think that's
what Democrats are gonna do or do you
think they're gonna pursue the most
radical agenda they can it was really
funny in 2008 there's a lot of talk
about President Obama being a unifying
figure that he was going to unify
America after the divisive Bush years
were gonna react by electing a man of
true unity there was only one problem
Barack Obama then immediately tacked his
hard to the left as it is possible to go
he had cash for clunkers he did stimulus
he did bailouts
he did tarp he did the he did Obamacare
aided all of those in the first year and
a half of his administration because he
said he won and he had the power
Democrats are trying to do the same
thing right now don't fall for the scam
even if you're not a fan of president
Trump's you have to acknowledge there's
another party in power then if they get
into power because of Trump they're not
going to be anodyne in their policy
prescriptions Nancy Pelosi makes this
clear right she would be the new Speaker
of the House again here's a Nancy Pelosi
saying exactly what she stands for San
Francisco values that's what we were
about the city of st. Francis
it's an anthem is the south of st.
Francis make us an instrument of thy
peace darkness light despair hope hatred
of all of that that's who we are hearts
are full of love for everyone in our
country colleagues have honored me with
titles and this or that and I say to
them I'm very honored but I had no
bigger honor than to walk on to the
floor of the house and speak people
obscenities ok San Francisco is the most
left-leaning city in the United States
and she is saying that our politics are
the politics of San Francisco the
politics of poop on every corner
the politics of sanctuary cities the
politics of extraordinarily high taxes
and extraordinarily high real estate
prices the politics of a city that used
to be nice now falling into ruin because
of democratic policy and that is the
politics of Nancy Pelosi and if we got
past Trump we would recognize that if it
were a referendum on democratic policy
people would react badly and it's not
just Nancy Pelosi when Democrats are
forced to embrace their own agenda it's
pretty obvious what they want here
Democrats have not made an affirmative
case why you should vote for them they
make a case why you should not vote for
President Trump
they say he's divisive but they
themselves are just as divisive or more
divisive and not only that their
policies are significantly more radical
hey Jake Tapper on CNN did a good job of
pushing Stacey Abrams Stacey Abrams is
the Democratic gubernatorial candidate
in Georgia she's running in a relatively
close race
she promised she shoe as a
representative pushed a bill pushed a
bill for a gun confiscation
here's tapper pushing her on it your
co-sponsor told reporters the law quote
would require gun owners of these
particular models to turn their guns in
and again my point is this the
legislation introduced was the beginning
of a conversation I am absolutely
certain that with were we to pass this
in Georgia we would have a conversation
about grandfathering in about whether or
not people would turn their guns in
whether there would be buybacks well
just to be clear no I'm just trying to
understand so youyou don't support the
actual legislation you just support
having a conversation about it no what
I've said is legislation in the state
legislature is about starting the
conversation so here's the deal
Democrats don't have an agenda to run on
the agenda they've been pushing is
really just an agenda of Republicans are
racist sexist bigoted homophobes the
same agenda they've been pushing my
entire life
basically now pushing that same agenda
down and on top of that agenda will be a
bunch of bad policy because this is what
they always do what they do is they say
ok to 2008 was a referendum on
Republican leadership and then Barack
Obama came in he said know what this
really was a referendum on was
nationalized health care which it
certainly was not the Democrats today
and the Democrats in the media are lying
and they are saying this election is
about Medicare it's not about Medicare
people are not voting based on Medicare
they are voting based on whether they
like Trump or not it's that simple this
is a referendum on President Trump and
the problem with referenda on
particularly partisan political figures
is that it ignores what's going to
happen after the referendum which means
that there is going to be a policy shift
and so Democrats in the end what are
they really campaigning on are they
really campaigning on Stacey Abrams gun
control or on Medicare or on Social
Security
are they really campaigning on any of
those things no what they are really
campaigning on is we think that there is
one side of the country that is hateful
and terrible vote for us how do we know
this because this is what they're
campaigning on I mean they're not hiding
the ball here President Obama back on
the stump and he is saying President
Trump is SuperDuper super corrupt I'm
like I'm like my I'm bust he's standing
there in front of a Andrew Gilliam he's
in front of Andrew Gilliam a man
actively under investigation by the FBI
for corruption
hey Andrew Gilliam was handed Hamilton
tickets by an undercover agent for the
FBI
in a sting operation designed to ferret
out corruption in Tallahassee city
government and Barack Obama is standing
in front of him in a rally saying
Republicans are corrupt
here's Barack Obama Thomas to take on
corruption instead they have racked up
enough indictments to feel the football
team I didn't have anybody in my
administration getting done
I mean I I just thought that's how
you're supposed to do things well write
what you thought is that your own
attorney general would be held in
contempt by Congress and then you'd
assert executive privilege to shield him
and then you'd make sure that your DOJ
didn't prosecute anybody the fact that
there are no indictments during during
Obama's administration demonstrates a
complete partisan hackery of zone goj
the fact that there are indictments
coming out of the Trump administration
is actually better evidence than his DOJ
is honest and then Obama's was Jeff
Sessions is an honest man DOJ is doing a
good job investigating and ferreting out
corruption even inside the party that
exists Barack Obama politicized his DOJ
to the point that Lois Lerner actively
cracked down on Republican 501 C 3s and
his DOJ did nothing about it nothing and
that's an that's evidence of his non
corruption I wrote an entire book called
the people vs. Barack Obama it's 200
pages about why people inside the Obama
administration should have been indicted
and an Obama suggestion is that the
other party is corrupt all they've got
this is all they've got now maybe it's
enough maybe it's enough because Trump
is such a polarizing figure because
Trump sucks up the publicity because
Trump sucks the oxygen ID little maybe
it's enough but let's not fool ourselves
there are consequences that come on the
back of an election cycle like this now
in just a second I want to talk a little
bit more about Democrat alarmism we've
heard a lot about Republican alarmism
about the caravan and I'll be frank with
you I'm I'm friendly to that argument I
think Republicans have been alarmist
about the caravan but Democrat alarmism
is no better in fact in many ways it's
significantly worse and then we'll talk
about anti-semitism and I got to talk
about this this SNL thing too there's a
lot to talk about but you're first gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm and
subscribe before we do that though let
me remind you that if you actually want
to get a fantastic president for a
present for anyone in your family you
need to head over to legacy box okay I
really this is an important service
there are a lot of services we use that
are fantastic this one is actually
important I'm a big believer that the
memories that you create during your
life have to be preserved in a safe way
because if those memories are gone then
you lose them you do and and one of
those memories are lost you're losing a
part of yourself
the legacy box ensures that doesn't
happen legacy box is a simple affordable
way to get your recorded moments
digitally preserved on DVD or thumb
drive here's how it works you load
legacy box with your old tapes film
pictures audio
Recordings and you send it back you get
them back in a couple of weeks on DVD or
a convenient thumb drive ready to watch
share and relive I get notes from folks
who have used legacy box on a fairly
regular basis telling me how much it is
meant to their family that they now have
all of these memories available for
quick access
legacy box takes care of everything they
provide updates at every step of the way
I've used legacy box for my parents it
makes a fantastic fantastic present
again for Christmas or Hanukkah go check
it out right now over 350,000 families
have used legacy box for a limited time
go to legacy box comm /ban enter my
promo code Ben got a 40% discount on
your order that's a legacy box comm /ban
again legacy box comm slash Ben go check
it out right now legacy box comm slash
Ben alrighty so for the rest of today's
show you're gonna need to go over to
daily wear comm we have so many goodies
so many goodies available to you when
you become a subscriber $9.99 a month
that means you get the rest of this show
live clayvin show live Knowles's
terrible show live yet Matt Walsh my
Matt Walsh show live you can check out
all those things plus tomorrow evening
starting at 8 p.m. Eastern I will be
here torturing myself by watching the
election live with you so if you're not
there let me tell you something I will
take that as a sign of disloyalty my
friends don't miss our next episode of
daily we are backstage election edition
when I suffer through a nine hour
session with God King Jeremy boring
Andrew Klavan
the execrable Michael moles Alicia
crafts will be there Colton Hass will be
there Cassy Dillon will be there all of
us will be there suffering together you
won't want to miss that
as always only daily wire subscribers
get to ask the question so make sure to
subscribe today and if I'm gonna put
myself through that man you could at
least have you could at least have the
loyalty to subscribe I mean come on for
the amount that we do for you here at
daily wire I'm insulted insulted if you
don't also don't miss Andrew clavin's
next chapter of another Kingdom
performed by the execrable Michael
Knowles today subscribers get exclusive
access to episode six titled he bought
me which is also a story about Andrew
Gilliam if you're not a subscriber you
won't be able to watch new episodes of
season 2 until Friday so what exactly
are you waiting for a go check it out
right now at daily wire.com subscribe to
watch the first and second seasons of
another kingdom so many goodies for you
when you get the annual subscription by
the way you got this the very greatest
and all beverage vessels chill the calm
flow through you as you grasp the
solidity of the leftist tiers hot or
cold tumbler feel the genius
infuse your brain as you take a sip from
this the very greatest known beverage
vessel so go check that out for an
annual subscription you get that as well
plus we're adding new subscriber
services all the time you're gonna want
to be part of the team and we really
appreciate you working with us we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
so as I say Democrats left with no
actual policy I left at the closing
pitch of Trump Trump Trump from from
from from and alarmism alarmism again
when the Democrats say Republicans are
alarmist about the caravan kinda okay
fair now but Democrats also say is that
illegal immigration is no problem which
is just idiotic and so now I have to
choose between should I be alarmist
about the caravan
and take illegal immigration seriously
or should I be not alarmist about the
caravan and say the legal immigration is
totally fine and have net benefits of
the United States if I have to make that
choice I'll go with choice number one
door number one even though I don't like
how the migrant Caravan is being covered
by the media okay but to suggest that
alarmism exists on only one side is the
purest form of gaslighting not only does
it not only exist on one side it is
significantly stronger on the left and
on the right is the left that has been
suggesting since Trump won the election
that it was the end of the world that we
were all going to die we were going to
be killed by net neutrality we were
going to be killed by the tax cuts we
were going to be killed by the
withdrawal from the Paris climate
Accords we were going to be killed by
Brett Kavanaugh his appointments at the
Supreme Court we were going to be killed
by every single thing Trump did on every
other day
president Trump was the destroyer of
worlds and they are still making that
case so if alarmism is a problem then
you might want to think about which
parties actually been more alarmist okay
and which party's being more dishonest
about that alarmism like hey look here's
Maxine water saying the president Trump
is promoting violence
Maxine freakin waters okay she's out
here in California I'm old enough to
remember the LA riots when she called in
LA uprising and suggested it was fine
for people to bust into other people's
stores and loot things because of racial
anger specifically I mean it was it was
actually racialized looting I mean it
was it was very heavy targeting of
Korean shop owners in South Central Los
Angeles and that was Maxine Waters it's
giving it the okay
who's Maxine Waters like three months
ago saying that people should be
confronted in public places over their
politics and now she's saying Trump is
promoting violence you think that
alarmism doesn't exist on the left it is
stronger on the left and it is on the
right so before he give me this whole
shtick about president Trump is alarmist
on illegal immigration at least illegal
immigration is an issue I'm not gonna
pretend that I think the president Trump
is a grave threat to the entire Republic
I don't think that's the guys and I
think anybody who thinks that is way out
over their skis but I think that
Maxine Waters left her skis a long time
ago she's tramping through the
underbrush in in basically those those
weird shoes that look like tennis
rackets here is Maxine Waters and he's
promoting violence I'm accustomed to
being threatened we have had at least
one individual indicted who threatened
to kill me
I have many threats to kill me from
different places in this country so I'm
accustomed to being threatened okay well
that's that's terrible
hey no one should be a customer as
someone who's received any threats and
somebody who had security on Shabbat
because of all the situations okay
like I'm warm to that argument but I'm
not warm to it coming from Maxine Waters
and Bill Maher goes on national TV on
Friday night and he says that if you're
18 and you live in the United States
thanks to the Republicans you might not
live in a democracy anymore really you
might not live in a democracy anymore
it's amazing I made the argument in 2016
to Republicans and to everybody else
that well the election was important
there would be more elections the
Republic would go on whether it was
Trump or Hillary there would be serious
consequences but there would be more
elections and there are people who are
alarmist saying on both sides no no
there will be no more elections I hold
to my original position Donald Trump is
not going to end the Republic that's
absurd but here is Bill Maher in front
of an American flag explaining the
Republic will end if Republicans win a
midterm election if Trump wins he will
cast it as a complete endorsement of his
most undemocratic behavior if you're 18
and that happens you stand a very real
chance of not living in a western-style
democracy for part or all of your life
yes it can happen here okay let's be
real about something if you're talking
about parties being validated and most
anti-democratic tendencies of those
parties being validated I'm much more
afraid of that from the Democrats than I
am from the Republicans I am Republican
policy is about devolution of authority
down to state and local levels it's
about less federal intervention ism or
at least it should be democratic policy
is about centralization of power every
time the Democrats have taken power
they've brought more power to the
federal level and made government less
democratic and less disel an unless
deference to the public
this is the Democrats closing argument
is alarmism and the final step in that
alarmism is about anti-semitism and here
I feel like I have some special weight
to talk about anti-semitism
so Barry Weiss who I'm friends with was
on Bill Maher show and she said some
good things about anti-semitism talking
about what anti-semitism is what the
theory of anti-semitism is and then she
said something with which I really
disagree and Barry and I you know we're
friends we talked pretty frequently
she's a columnist over at the New York
Times here is here is Barry talking
about American Jews and president Trump
and I think that this is alarmist and I
don't think it's correct here she is
there are many Jews including Jews that
I know who have liked many of Trump's
policies regarding Israel in Middle East
they love the fact that the embassy was
moved to Jerusalem the move that I
supported they like the scuttling of the
Iran deal but I hope this week that
American Jews have woken up to the price
of that bargain dignity for all human
beings equality under the law respect
for dissent love of truth these are the
things that we are losing under this
president okay so let's stop that for a
second okay so when she says the price
of the bargain is that American Jews
signed off on moving the embassy to
Israel and therefore it bargained away
11 Jews got shot at a synagogue I think
it's a really a really bad thing for
Mary to say I think I do not think that
that is right maybe she didn't mean it
that way I'll seem best of intentions
that she phrased that badly because I
don't think she meant it that way but
that is an argument that was openly made
by people like Julia Joffe that
President Trump the bargain American
Jews made was move embassy its Jerusalem
in return for 11 Jews being shot to
death if that is not how anti-semitism
works nor is it how Jewish policy works
and when she talks about the and when
she talks about you know the the fact
that facts have become secondary and
polarization is real I agree I agree
with a lot of that but guess what that
is not relegated to one side and this
isn't what about ISM this is a
recognition of reality on the ground
this is a recognition of reality on the
ground now let's talk about
anti-semitism for a second because the
closing argument that's being made by a
lot of folks on the left on the
political left and buries more than
Center but there the argument is being
made more openly by folks on the
political left that essentially Donald
Trump forwarded and fomented
anti-semitism and therefore we have to
punish the
publican party let's talk about
anti-semitism broadly and in the United
States there are three types of
anti-semitism I spoke in Vancouver
Hebrew Academy last week is where I said
there are three types of anti-semitism
there's left doing anti-semitism there
is right-wing anti-semitism there is
radical Muslim anti-semitism those are
the three major types of anti-semitism
on planet earth today
right wing anti-semitism this is sort of
white supremacist anti-semitism this has
existed for as long as I've been alive
there have been major anti-semitic
incidents from white supremacists every
single presidency of my lifetime there
was one during Clinton there's one
during Bush there's one during Obama and
then there was this one okay so that
exists it will continue to exist and as
I said before when Trump Winton nodded
at the alt-right in 2015 and 2016 there
was literally no one on planet earth
more critical of that than I was go back
and listen to the show now there are two
other types of anti-semitism and if you
want to talk about grave threats to the
Jewish people all over the world not
just in the United States the
combination of left-wing anti-semitism
that has infused the Democratic Party
and Muslim anti-semitism that is being
let in the backdoor of Europe by
left-wing anti-semites hey that is much
more of a threat to Jews all over the
world and the left ignores this stuff
ignores it openly
hey anti-semitism is not on the ballot
the reason it's not on the ballot is
because the Democrats are not an answer
to anti-semitism Keith Ellison was
almost the head of the DNC there are two
separate candidates running in this
election cycle who have openly open more
than two actually at least two who have
openly embraced boycott divestment and
sanctions of the State of Israel over
the weekend there are a bunch of kids in
New York City who threw a pole through a
window at a New York City show and I
know we're not supposed to talk about
anti-semitism in New York City or the
fact that hate crimes in New York City
are largely perpetuated by members of
minority communities who have a lot of
loyalty of folks like Al Sharpton and
Louis Farrakhan we're supposed to
pretend it's all a bunch of white
supremacists in New York City but
anti-semitism in New York City is not
coming from white supremacists and this
is not an excuse for white supremacist
who should all be forcibly expelled from
the United States if that were possible
and if that weren't constitutionally
illegal their their ideology is evil but
to pretend that endorsement of the Left
is somehow fighting back against
anti-semitism is nuts it's just nuts and
to pretend that the mainstream policy of
both
medical parties is widely disparate is
also nuts the Republican Party is far
more Philo Semitic in policy and
attitude than the Democratic Party is
they are and I understand that there are
folks on the Left who want to suggest
that anti-semitism is related in essence
to Jewish left-wing politics and that if
you and that the real reason for
anti-semitism is because Jews are
left-wing that is not the real reason
for anti-semitism the reason for
anti-semitism is because of
anti-semitism people hate right-wing
Jews they hate left-wing Jews they hate
Jews I want to discuss that a little
more in just a second so let's talk
about the policies the variant policies
with regard to Jews on both sides of the
political aisle so first of all Louis
Farrakhan Rhino people pretend that
Louis Farrakhan isn't a relevant part of
America's public life that is a why lose
Farrakhan is a relevant part of American
public life it was Bill Clinton standing
next to him at Aretha Franklin's funeral
like a month ago Louis Farrakhan went
over to Iran where he chanted death to
the Jews in Persian okay so really good
guy blues Farrakhan you still haven't
heard from Linda Sarsour on this we
still haven't heard from any of the
Democratic Party higher-ups on all of
this hey there's a woman in Tooele Hana
Omar who is running for teeth Ellison's
old seat she's probably gonna win okay
she has engaged an openly anti-semitic
rhetoric the Democratic Party embraces
her and champions her as a as a part of
their intersectional coalition KO Han
Omar is as far left as humanly possible
here's what she tweeted in 2012 quote
Israel has hypnotized the world may
Allah awaken the people and help them
see the evil doings of Israel he says
she again these folks are part of the
Democratic Party base and not only part
of the base they are part of the actual
Democratic Party now they're folks on
the Left you say well what about Steve
King people like Steve King Steve King
has flirted with white supremacist
groups in recent months he flirted with
a woman named faith Goldie up in Toronto
who has a history of being involved with
white supremacist causes he went over to
Europe and hung out with the freedom
party in Austria all of these are bad
ones and you know what happened the NRCC
condemned him when's the last time ill
Hanauma
was condemned by anyone or Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez by the way who's an ally
of Linda Sarsour and Ilhan Omar
meanwhile the the Democratic Party is
the same party that greenlit the Iran
deal while claiming that Israel was to
blame for all of the problems in the
Middle East it was the Democratic Party
that tried to cut off support for Israel
in the middle of the Gaza war in 2014 it
was Barack Obama who lied
who let the Iranian regime slaughter
people in the streets in 2009 then lied
about their moderation in order to push
forward his crap around nuclear deal so
to pretend that the only threat to Jews
is white supremacists who are active on
reddit boards and therefore vote for
Democrats it's like saying that there
are right-wingers right-wing
anti-semites in Britain who have been
promoted by the Conservative Party or
you Kuip therefore vote for Jeremy
Corbyn and Labour know the Trump
administration by the way is also
fighting back against anti-semites
around the world here's Mike Pompeo
talking about new sanctions on Iran
these sanctions apply to those who
conduct sanctionable transactions the
Treasury has a set of sanctions the
State Department has its own set of
sanctions and those will all come back
into place on Monday of this week and
there'll be the toughest sanctions ever
placed against the Islamic Republic of
Iran now I know that we may be too
stupid to hold two truths and ones but
there are a couple of truths we need to
hold it ones one Trump can take some bad
stuff that I don't like to his policy
can be extraordinarily proud you in
pro-israel both of those things are true
and here's the truth about the Democrats
a lot of Democrats have some pretty
horrible things about Jews and their
policy is anti-israel so there's that as
well okay all of these things can be
true at once it means that politics is
complex and nuanced but the Democratic
Party is like the reactionary nature of
I don't like Trump they're from a vote
for the party of Andrew Gilliam and
Ilhan Omar and Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
with the ideology of Jeremy Corbyn you
explain how it's logical to me that
makes perfect sense only if you're
honestly if you lost the thread you
attend for some things I like and some
things that I hate so things that I like
today first of all since there is one
more day I felt it necessary to play the
only other good number from laymen's the
first good number from Lima is I've sung
myself
stars it's not a good performance but if
you want to actually go see a good
performance you can go see I think it's
what's the name of the guy who plays it
Philip Quast
quest he played the original shop here
who's the hero of limas but here is the
here is one day more which is the the
culminating number of the first act this
musical is about three years long so the
good news is when you hit the end of the
first act you're only you know a year
and a half older here is here is one day
more from lame is the best number in the
in the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I will join these the post
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you're gonna play the whole
thing but um you know I'm one of the few
people who actually likes the movie of
lemmas better than I like the actual
stage musical cuz it's it's shorter
although they made a huge mistake when
they did the movie which is in the old
days when they did a musical they
actually got people could sing meaning
they actually got pee and they would
voice people over right Natalie Wood is
sung by Marni Nixon in West Side Story
virtually everybody in West Side Story
is voiced over Richard Boehner is voiced
over as as Tony pretty much everybody in
that musical is voiced over in fact so
many people are voiced over in West Side
Story that there's one point where the
where Rita Moreno is character is voiced
over by a woman in Betty Wan and she was
absent one day so Marni Nixon had to
voice her over so there's a point where
Marni Nixon is singing with Marni Nixon
in the soundtrack to West Side Story has
two different characters but you know
better that then they have Russell Crowe
singing Javert yeah
mistake okay other things that I like so
I know that manure of folks who listen
to this show have no idea who PewDiePie
is that's because there's an entire
subculture on the internet you have no
idea about PewDiePie has 69 million
subscribers on YouTube and a couple of
weeks ago PewDiePie said in one of his
videos that he had to have mijo
something he called me review which is
where he actually looked at various
memes on the internet and then laughs at
them and then we sort of got in
connection and we actually did cut part
of his meme review and and so we
appeared in a PewDiePie video because
this is our life now and it's pretty
funny so here's some of that I have a
super special intel scoop that if we all
say okay this is epic with enough
passion to destroy licked or with enough
courage to salvage their tears we can
summon ben shapiro to do bonus me this
is for bonus me we can redirect him from
the dead but only by the power of okay
this is so epic ben shapiro memes
this is it okay say it with me
[Applause]
is
it's just
okay Ben Shapiro do we have time for
bonus mean so PewDiePie asked me to
review some memes memes are this thing
where people put funny stuff on my phone
here is one of these memes let's go so
it's really funny and again this has
like five million views this silliness
is like five million views in two days
over at PewDiePie so thanks to PewDiePie
for making that happen and thanks to my
staff for humoring all of us in doing
that it's pretty funny as you can go
check that out okay time for some things
that I hate the character attacks on
Republicans are not restricted of course
to President Trump every Republican is
evil in the view of a lot of Democrats
Gloria Steinem who knows as much about
marriage as your average duck she she
suggested the Brett Kavanaugh she hates
Brett's Cavanaugh why she ate bread nah
because something she says the only
thing worse than Brett cabinet on the
Supreme Court is being married to him
because the woman who said that a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
is an expert now on marital I'm marital
Accord
here's Gloria Steinem finally the
interviewer asked her a question and he
answered I mean she opened her mouth but
never gay not that came out that moved
right in that says it all right I mean
the one thing worse than having him on
the Supreme Court is to be married to
him say the terrible terrible women of
Gloria Steinem Jane Fonda and Robin
Morgan if you're glow if you're closing
pitch to the election is Gloria Steinem
Jane Fonda who actually sided with the
Vietcong in the middle of a war and
Robin Morgan a radical feminist then
good luck to you it's not just them I
love that the Democrats are now opening
all of the asylums and letting out the
inmates Barbara Streisand has done some
new music and in this new music she rips
on President Trump so she showed up on
Bill Maher which was just a crazy place
on Friday night apparently she showed up
and she said she can't sleep nights
because living in Malibu in a palatial
estate that she tried to sue a
photographer for taking an aerial
photograph of being extraordinarily
wealthy and being able to perform songs
for a living she can't sleep nights
because Donald Trump is the President of
the United States and that means end of
world for people like Barbara Streisand
what would I love bar
Reisen is every two years she says if
Republicans win I'm gonna move to Canada
and then she looks at the tax rates in
Canada and she's like I'm gonna stay
here and fight for my country
so here's bill maher with Barbara
Streisand I wanted so on my mind Trump
is so on my mind
hmm you channeled it into this I
couldn't smell buds and so I was
thinking oh my god now the the
photographs in my head the pictures you
know the children being ripped out of
the arms of their parents okay so yes
I'm sure that she was very deeply
worried about the children being ripped
out of the arms and their parents when
it was Barack Obama doing it now of
course it she can't sleep nights about
it but it is true that folks in
California who live in like the richest
areas go to the finest restaurants who
sit there shipping 100 bottle $100
bottles of Chardonnay at lunchtime
before going back to their offices where
they do minimal work on the arts and
then gaze at their Warhol paintings like
those people are so upset about Trump
because in the end these elections are
really about character and unfortunately
no one has any so that's that's what
it's become it's become a referendum on
character everybody thinks the other
side is evil and nobody is able to make
anything like a compelling political
argument for their positions that
there's that a final thing that I hate
today
I do have to acknowledge the insane
irony of this headline from the New York
Times
Brian Kemp's office without citing
evidence investigate Georgia Democrats
over alleged hack here's the story for
weeks Brian Kemp the Georgia Secretary
of State and Republican candidate for
governor has faced accusations that he's
trying to suppress the minority vote in
his race against Stacey Abrams and just
days ago a federal judge ruled the state
needed to adjust elements of its
so-called exact match voting requirement
calling them needlessly burdensome now
in what Democrats had was a desperate
attempt to deflect attention just two
days before a crucial midterm mr. Kemp
used his official position Sunday to
announce with scant evidence that the
Democrats were under investigation for
allegedly trying to hack the state's
voter registration files weird let me
just change a couple of words there and
and we'll reread that again for weeks
Barack Obama
the President of the United States and
his Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
faced accusations that they were trying
to suppress Republican votes in their in
their vote in their race against Donald
Trump and just days ago a federal judge
ruled that the federal government needed
to adjust elements of its requirements
calling them needlessly Bergesen now in
what here's the part now in
Republicans said was a desperate attempt
to deflect attention just two days
before a presidential election Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama used their
official position to announce with scant
evidence that the Republicans were under
investigation for allegedly trying to
hack the election weird how the New York
Times is totally cool with all sorts of
allegations without serious evidence
that the Republicans were hacking the
election but as soon as it see Georgia
Republican investigating then all of a
sudden it's scant evidence how dare he
weird how that works very very weird
it's almost as though the media are
biased mm-hmm okay well we'll be back
here tomorrow with the final final final
episode before the election results
start to roll in try to rest up because
tomorrow is gonna be a long day
particularly for me so I'll be there
with you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018